hey drew how are you uh
by the way what a boy's fantasy room
you're in
yeah this is this is what i call stray
land it's my man cave
slash storage slash car place if you're
if you're a dude and you like that kind
of stuff this is the right
place for you this is didn't get any
better for me at least
i uh oh wow if i had to build my
ultimate chick cave
i think yeah i know exactly what it
would look like
um extreme what would it look like uh
you know let's see
can you say it on morning tv i don't
think i can
but uh definitely something out of the
60s
um and a lot of macrame and
smudge sticks with sage and you know
um a lot of books there'd be a lot of
books
yeah it'd be groovy groovy i like that
very groovy
yeah michael let me ask you a question
which is actually
about asking questions now do you like
being interviewed more or do you like
interviewing people more it's weird
because i don't know
i think i like being interviewed more
because i have to think less
but then i like interviewing people
because i kind of control the interview
well i'm confused but i like this
because i'm on your show
and i gotta say i have to say i'm very
um i'm proud of you
and i'm happy for you because this is
perfect for you this fits your
personality
everybody loves you i love you and i'm
just proud to be a part of your show so
congratulations
thank you you have no idea how much
that means first of all from you i just
i'm such a huge fan and i think the
world of you and
i also love the fact that we are
both now in this job and i also think
there's
a wonderful real life
quality to a job like this as far as
i'm i'm not playing a character you're
not exactly
getting potentially injured at sports
the uh it's i'm trying to think of how
to equate sports and actually
you don't know but well sports and
acting are very similar in my opinion
because i've done
i've done a little bit of both i guess
but you have to be prepared you have to
be
focused you have to be at the moment you
have to to be on top of what you're
supposed to do and be a great teammate
to everybody else around you and
and your performance could sink
or sink or swim you know the whole
project
and i always look back at my career and
i've had an incredible pivot
uh to the point of where sometimes i
wonder did i ever play football because
things so far away
so long ago but it's about not being
afraid to challenge yourself for it and
seeing
what happens and for both of us it seems
to work so i keep stopping my stop now
i will ask a question which is i grew up
you know in hollywood and boy there's a
lot of egos to manage
in that world and is it the same
in the sports world oh absolutely
absolutely i
there are so many guys that who i
thought were amazing players on the
field but off the field they lived a
life that i didn't want
and there were guys who were not so good
on the field to live a great amazing
lives off the field i did watch i took
what was best that i felt for me from
everybody around me and i
and i made it the life that i wanted it
to be
and as you said there's so much to
manage when it comes to egos and even
your own ego at times and for me i never
let things go to my head because as
quick as you have success
it's as quick as you can lose success
and what you do is not who you
are and i think that's the lesson that
i've learned over all my years of doing
what i've been doing
yeah that's i really relate to that i
will always have that little
conscience on my shoulder that little
jiminy cricket that goes
appreciate everything you have work for
everything you have earn
it do not expect it yeah and you know
you have to earn everything and i
learned that from my dad who was in the
military
and i here in my in my man cave i have a
bmx bike
it's a kuahara laser light and back in
the 80s it was the hottest bike going
i wanted this bike so bad my dad said if
you can earn
half the money i'll pay for the other
half so i had to earn like 600 bucks 500
600 bucks
i cut all that grass i did everything i
could do to earn the money
and i still had that bike to this day
because the bike to me symbolizes that
nothing is
free you have to earn everything in your
life
and that hard work leads to good things
and that's how you get the things that
you really want so
i look at the bike i smile it's the most
valuable thing
in here maybe not in dollar terms but as
far as sentimentally to me because it
represents
the first time in my life that i had to
earn any earn something
and that's why i value it so much and
life is about
earning respect not more not just money
but it's about earning respect
and um and and all the things
all the good things gotta earn them and
you're a dad
to daughters and you know
i love seeing your affirmations or your
posts with them
what do you think is important to raise
good girls it's my life's mission so i'm
asking a good dad
to give your kid the time to show up and
be there so that they see their face
when they're at something that means a
lot to them
is the ultimate part about being a dad
and
my twin girls are now 16 years old
and they're bugging me about driving
and and all these things and it's it's
so hard as a father because to me
they're still my babies i don't want to
let them go
but at some point i realize that's going
to happen but until then they're going
to know that their father loves them
with everything that he has and that i'm
always here for them
and that's the most important thing for
me as far for raising
any child but i just happen to be a girl
dad so i'm proud of that
i am a girl mom michael this is perfect
and you're teaching your daughter to
drive
yes if you want to call it that it's
stressful
i guess that's what i'm trying to say
it's very stressful
but i have to do it and i i love it
though i love it and i do get nervous
i i do get nervous i'm kind of a control
freak behind the wheel of a car
by the way fun fact my friend
bought her kid a car that's a stick
shift
so they cannot text while driving
smart smart friend that's that that's
exactly what i thought make sure you get
a stick shift so they cannot
text and drive because that is so
important and so dangerous your friend
is really smart
it just terrifies me like the idea of my
daughters growing up
and you know facing all of those things
like dating and driving
and well the dating the dating part the
dating part i'm still not
too keen on and i i tell you what the
first
of when the boy showed up i'm going to
have my shoulder pads on
i'm going to have my arms greased down
i'm going to have a helmet on i'm going
to have
black stripes under my eyes and i'm
going to make sure i'm just certain
who you here to see
michael will you please come to my house
too
because i would love to se to present
and
just stand next to you like this
on demand you let me know i'm there full
uniform
ready to scare them away okay good now
michael by the way i think that you have
a little problem issue in your life
something that is in the wheelhouse of
something
i happen to be obsessed with uh yeah i
i really like my green juice in the
morning i like my coffee
but i have also a tendency to spill them
on myself
and create stains and i know you are the
master stain remover
i do love stain removal and
i know that you have a gorgeous line of
suits
at men's warehouse and you have all
these amazing collaborations
but i have some of your green
juice coffee stain suits right here and
i'm about to put my football helmet on
shoulder pads like paint and just
get ready